Knallige Autos, flatternde Petticoats
und mitreißende Musik.
Die Rock ’n’ Roll-Ära von Elvis Presley
eroberte die Welt im Sturm
und begeistert Fans noch heute.
Ich bin in Cleveland, Ohio, in der Nähe der
Rock-’n’-Roll-Hall-of-Fame' aufgewachsen.
Von klein auf war Elvis für mich der
King of Rock ’n’ Roll.
Ich wusste nicht, dass er auch in
Deutschland gelebt hat.
Erst recht nicht in dieser kleinen Stadt,
die jedes Jahr das Europäische
Elvis-Festival veranstaltet.
Ich will wissen, was hier so los ist.
Elvis Presley wurde 1958, auf dem
Höhepunkt seiner Karriere,
von der US-Armee eingezogen und in
der deutschen Stadt Friedberg stationiert.
Der benachbarte Ort
Bad Nauheim in Hessen
sollte für rund anderthalb Jahre sein
Zuhause werden.
Heute lädt die Stadt den Rest der Welt zum
17. Europäischen Elvis-Festival ein.
Mal gucken, ob sie den Geist von Elvis und
Rock ’n’ Roll heraufbeschwören kann.
Drei Tage lang dreht sich in Bad Nauheim
alles um den King of Rock ’n’ Roll:
mit Autos, Mode, Musik und Tanz aus
den 50er-Jahren.
Was begeistert die Festivalbesucher
heute noch an dieser Ära?
Rock ’n’ Roll ist halt sehr schön,
man kann sich schön anziehen,
man kann schön tanzen – das macht Spaß.
Elvis, Elvis, Elvis. Ich liebe Elvis.
Toller Mann, toller Sänger,
toller Entertainer!
Meine Frau steht auf den Look von Elvis
und stylt mir immer genauso die Haare.
Was ich wirklich mag, ist, dass Menschen
hier sind, denen die Musik wichtig ist.
Das finde ich toll, weil dadurch lebt
es halt auch weiter.
Die meisten der Musiker hier
sind keine Elvis-Imitatoren,
allerdings ist er für sie nach wie
vor eine große künstlerische Inspiration.
Auch für Grammy-Gewinnerin
Darlene Love,
die einst gemeinsam mit dem King
auf der Bühne stand.
Für die Elvis-Party am Abend sind
Tanzkünste gefragt.
Spätestens am zweiten Festival-Tag haben
in der Stadt tausende Elvis-Fans das Sagen.
Dieses Auto erinnert an den berühmten
rosa Cadillac des Sängers.
Der war bekannt dafür anzuhalten,
um Autogramme zu geben,
was ihm den Namen „Elvis, das
Verkehrshindernis“ einbrachte.
Das war übrigens nicht das einzige Mal,
dass er in Schwierigkeiten geriet.
Hotel-Manager Thomas Dröscher erzählt,
warum der King und seine
gesamte Entourage
nach nur wenigen Monaten aus dem
Hotel Grunewald rausgeworfen wurden.
Der Hauptgrund war,
dass sie Zeitungen angezündet
und dann das Feuer ausgeblasen haben.
Das rauchende Papier haben sie dann
vor andere Zimmer gelegt
und fanden es lustig, als die alten Damen
hinausgelaufen sind und dachten,
das Hotel würde brennen.
Irgendwann hat der Hotelbesitzer
dann gesagt: Okay, jetzt reicht es!
Heute können Fans ab 150 Euro pro Nacht
in dem original erhaltenen
Zimmer übernachten.
Elvis-Fans sind normalerweise freundlich,
gut gelaunt und lustig.
Oder sie weinen vor Glück.
Gestern war eine Frau hier,
die hat das Bett geküsst.
Im Ernst? Wirklich!
Offensichtlich brauchte der King eine
Menge Spiegel, um sich zu stylen.
Allein in diesem Zimmer sind sechs davon.
Fast überall wird man in Bad Nauheim
an Elvis Presley erinnert.
Besucher können während einer geführten
Tour in seine Fußstapfen treten.
Der Rundgang führt auch an seinem Haus
in der Goethestraße 14 vorbei,
in dem er seine spätere Ehefrau Priscilla
Beaulieu auf einer Party kennenlernte.
Das Haus wurde damals ständig
von Fans aus aller Welt belagert.
Das Elvis-Festival nähert sich dem Ende.
Fans haben bei mehr als fünfzig
Veranstaltungen ihr Idol gefeiert.